hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to me
I am officially out of exile which means
that I can play games once again and
return to the world of YouTube and ruin
it with my presence and my stupidity but
that doesn't mean that you guys aren't
happy to see some horrific horror games
the likes of which you've probably never
seen now a few things before we get
started in this very important so pay
attention to me very very very closely
number one Australia we're coming to you
November we're going on tour right to
your front door so check the link in the
description for ticket information about
our tour and Amsterdam if you didn't
know we're coming back to you baby
we may have canceled the first show but
we are coming back in full force in July
so check the link in the description
below to see when we're gonna be coming
to you and how you can see us so this is
in some this that blood on the wall
that's blood on the wall this is in some
nests a scary game that compares itself
to em new use headphones in a controller
what about these hands what about these
these fing DS I got a keyboard I'm gonna
try that now yeah I've been looking for
you for a long time
nobody can separate us not even satire
okay
okay I like the swinging light that's
real nice
oh yeah the slight moisture on the floor
don't seem too good oh I got it okay
lucky me on the good drawer is there any
other throw that I can use here was that
one highlighted just for that particular
reason okay um to interact with Mouse
what about this one though what about
this one okay bad choice is all over the
place well let's see what's down this
one first I opened it first it didn't
change my mind I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to the other
one I'm gonna go down here no no oh no
oh oh what a wholesome family oh okay
[Music]
all right this is cool I love it I love
the decorations is that mine can I pick
that up are you gonna be my lamp
[Music]
to use the flashlight I don't like I
don't like it at all Oh No just gonna
close that whoa damn you okay all right
we're gonna forget that exists okay all
right Oh all right what if I don't want
to go down the stairs what if I don't
want to do that why does it make an
ominous noise would have produce stairs
all right screw you I'm going down it oh
good it's just a tour probably oh gosh
Sam's gone it's a happy one just don't
seem so happy
look it's my bad is it nap time all
right
okay okay no my Barbie standing up
nobody stands up in the bed look
disaster at orphanage no carbon dioxide
leak has claimed its victims this
evening at 11:39 boom at the New England
hospice or vidur's in the nearby town of
five adults their children have died 10
of the under ages have been sent to the
hospital with serious respiratory
problems
Veterans Day get the official hood for
your domestic Eagle fifty percent off of
all patriotic items that's real nice
jiggly jiggly drawer there any my you
know how to open the jiggly drawer
anybody know that you're trying to open
it it ain't open hey guys Oh Gucci Gucci
go go - go - go okay all right you're
really asleep then oh I suppose oh oh
it's a puzzle don't you're good to go oh
there's blood on you okay okay so every
other clock is kind of doing a thing
okay that's enough Matt sister ramen
random ambiance guess that clock is
doing that okay so it's either I gotta
set it to the one that everybody else
and conform to the booze whoa of this
room
or I got a I got try something else
okay let's try ding ding
Oh Oh No
but how will I play goochy goochy goo no
I play this little piggy runs away oh
you know what all right you want to
fight huh oh he's scared did I scare you
did my manly screams of delight scare
you you shouldn't be afraid of little
old me oh good up i like up up is good
the movie up was great
we're going up till the beginning well
nevermind then we're not going quite up
then okay
[Music]
all right I don't like that baby
okay I have a light now can I look hey I
got key what does the key do is a key
for the up this is good for me is it bad
for me I mean nothing in a game like
this is gonna be good for me it's all
gonna surmount to something bad for me
it's good it's party room break out the
non-alcoholic booze I can't drink all
right let's have a good time with some
soda pops the new england hospital
finish is investigated for possible
sexual abuse well that's not good New
York please shoot dead black man holding
a metal pipe that's not good the man was
shot 10 times by four officers that's
also not good okay alright am I supposed
to am I supposed to glean some important
information out of this for you
[Music]
the new face of Maru what I'm hearing
from that I don't know if it's what I
should be hearing but it's what I'm
hearing so I'm gonna move on yeah okay
party room will green is no go how about
party room pink Oh
party room pink it's the party room red
okay all right hello these doors don't
work so I'm guessing I just got to walk
down the ominous hallway filled with
religious paraphernalia and creepy ugly
behind me I'll wait outside doing okay
I'll take that yeah I'll take what's
mine no one can stop me you booze wob
bastards can't even control me too good
for you
did I need this for some reason I need
to go down here whatever dude booze what
bastards can't even stop me
nobody can or something
[Music]
Oh stranger danger stranger danger
excuse you excuse you that's what I
thought
that's what I like that sucks plan
looking dude all right
oh no you know what no I that doesn't
make sense I was really gonna make a
snarky comment about the decoration but
now just know I don't like Modern Art it
doesn't work for me hanging a door
covered in blood over a big old stairway
it's stupid I don't get the meaning of
it whatever fine oh we got here
missing girl police desperate to find
missing girl eight who vanished on
Easter Sunday seven most contaminated
fish you should avoid eating bye
Underwood the first blue typewriter the
future is now said Edward hipster
hello oh this looks nice actually
oh oh I thought those were heads oh okay
call six three three five two six three
eight three five two or is it six three
eight oh there's only four that I can
okay Paul
maybe it's just eight three five two
eight five hmm
damn it okay I don't know what that is
maybe I've got some incomplete
information here maybe there's something
else the picture kind of showed that the
whole place was topsy-turvy so then
maybe there's something to that or maybe
it's in another room and I gotta come
back here anybody else here
[Music]
one in 118 one I guess is three that's
two so eight one is it the order it goes
in it's the only thing I can guess right
8 1 9 a 1 9 this place gives me the
heebie-jeebies 8 1 9 a 1 no wait no aah
the picture is pertaining to the this
one that one pertained to this one so 8
1 9 but maybe it's not that 8 1 9 7 that
was on the second floor so it's 8 1 9 7
but the sevens on the second so maybe
the 7 is the second number okay I think
I got that means 9 is the last number 8
1 9 7 so blank
so it's either one seven eight nine or
eight one seven nine one eight seven
nine no one seven eight nine or eight
one seven nine
oh okay great
my ears are dead what does that do for
me oh there's another cross on the wall
here okay I got to look I could double
fish crosses I can't kill two vampires
at the same time man I'm really min/max
in my efficiency here my body oh that's
all right okay well I got two crosses so
what wait okay I'm Jana picking up a
mental image there's a cross on that
door and there's a cross on that door so
it's gotta be this door I knew it you
can't outsmart me
I ain't got no brains for nothing I
don't like it when I walk into a room
and there's a pipe filled with blood
immediately adjacent oh you need boobs
okay all right I got to find some really
flat boobs put on here I understand I
see what you're getting at
III see I see what you're going for here
okay
so if I am reading the room correctly I
need to go her bangle and then her ankle
oh yeah oh that is the good stuff
Oh oh no that's the good stuff okay all
right just sorry this priceless art that
I just Yankee janked out of the way here
oh I see I see what whoo i okay who's
like the triple take that because that
looked like a person I'm sorry I'm
stupid whole thing in the world calls
them bloody if people are proud to
follow Greeks after them
I want a fearful love okay this is
obviously pretending to the paintings
you're telling it in order right okay
whole thing in the world calls the my
greens I want the people wrong so the
last one I was in a peaceful life it
obviously has something to do with these
paintings so I wasn't a peaceful life is
that a peaceful life I don't know calls
them death I guess that's death I don't
know
yeah sure okay how about that that all
thinking the world calls them blind in
people are green
I want the people wrong okay maybe I
don't have the order because I don't
know which ones one I don't know which
ones do I don't know which was three
this one could
be death that's not a peaceful life
these these mostly are death peaceful
life this be peaceful that's pretty
peaceful okay alright so it's something
to do with that let me check the other
didn't open you and I definitely didn't
put my radioactive Tootsie's on that
floor there's some going on whoa bossy
bossy okay all right so I got to follow
the map
how the Frick freckle or you spot how am
I supposed to memorize this how the how
the ding-dang dingle dong or am I
supposed to do that
[Music]
alright here we go
no no oh I see I get a check ball well I
goof this real hard didn't I okay
there's a checkpoint right there so
that's easy enough that's easy enough
okay then give me checkpoints makes you
easier on me
oh that's just stupid it's easy look at
me look at me go oh look at me I'm just
keep going on yeah I'm go back oh good
thing I got such a bill okay that was
quick all right well fine uh-huh okay
all right I see oh look at me
okay coddle you well that's not gonna
you know what I got it okay that made it
a little too easy some people some
babies with tiny brains probably
complained about this this puzzle and it
wasn't me because I'm too smart for it
but here we are easy breezy beautiful
thank you got it all right I'm Audi no
one haunting me on the way out cuz I'll
just sprained probably like a little
[ __ ] baby alright so then it's just
this one and I gotta figure out which
one's ruin ones well which ones just
flipping switches switches out just
flipping okay wait a minute hang on I
got a not gonna psychoanalyze phase cuz
this is a bunch of okay I thought this
was the adverse in the envious one that
seems like that that do that three three
words in there I was like dude that's
good but what is this what is this cause
I'm blind all they have death
whatever whatever I'll take it okay
we're moving on we're moving on cuz we
got everything that we need them we
don't need to be there anymore so let's
go put the boobs on the boob machine and
we can get whatever good
you have to sacrifice the bow focus with
the hell come [ __ ] okay yeah stick
that bad boy right in there to slam jam
it right in the yam okay all right
well that's just too bad
well I mean that was just really my
stupidity for sticking my hand in a hole
with a lot of blows oh that that's it
why God would throw that trouble just
get my hand chopped off but I didn't
even see what was in the up upstairs or
did I wait no did I I did I did I did
okay all right well I guess that's scary
oh I guess I guess I am well that would
be those good I was having a good time
but that ending is this just a demo or
is that the full game I guess it's a
full game I I don't understand and I
don't get the meaning from it I don't
glean any extra information from it but
it was good it was definitely good it
just needed a little extra you know what
I mean but don't you worry that is just
the first game that we're gonna be
playing today oh we've got more huh okay
so this one might be silly it might be
scary but I know that I'm gonna do great
at this one because this game is called
survival of the smartest and if you know
one thing about me they say I'm real
smart
so it's real slow so we're in the most
horrible place you could possibly think
of school I know a lot of you have just
gotten out of school and you don't you
don't want to even think you don't even
think of this Oh No which is the right
way to go well if I go right then it's
probably thing like oh it's the right
way to go but if I'm using my big brain
I know that it's a trick question and
you're saying that the left is the right
wing yeah oh yeah oh I know how this is
okay how many red stripes are there on
the United States flag oh can you see by
the dawn's early light I'm trying to get
myself back into school when we did the
Pledge of Allegiance all day every day I
stared at that big beautiful flag the
door and break light out of Galilee
Stram nein nein Oh
terrify is it getting darker this is me
real character foghorn Jay Leghorn I'm
I'm not I'm not I'm not a chicken I'm a
rooster I get it okay right answer you
know if I'm right I mean I know I'm
right they're not that Tasmanian
Deauville Mac how is an autonomous
territory belonging to which country I
don't know Mac cow goes Moo Gua a guru
Gua good you are gay
let's go this way oh well done
hey easy there big scary screaming
contest huh what is the favorite food of
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
although hotdogs barely anything here I
think what you telling me that the TMNT
favorite food is hot dogs I'm smart
I'm a smart cookie I'm a good noodle
don't take away my star all right which
Christian missionary is said to a bit
banished all the snakes from Island
isn't that Saint Patrick isn't that what
that's all about he had a stick or a
flute or something I don't know
Ireland suffered from the great famine
beginning in 1845 due to the collapse of
what crop her taters wait no was it just
potatoes wouldn't wasn't it it's saying
beginning to the collapse of crop maybe
no they don't grow rice in Ireland
potatoes not getting darker here
penicillin was discovered in 1928 by
which scientist is that Fleming what's
that Fleming yeah Fleming I'm going back
to my high school days
Fleming no death for me cause I'm smart
I'm smart cookie was he if it's a
language of Greenland Greenlandic we
speak Greenlandic air yep I'm going with
Greenlandic Greenlandic that's a
language which is the most abundant
metal in the earth crust it's I'm
thinking it's it gotta be iron I mean
I mean the earth has a big ol iron ball
sack in the center of it I don't know if
that means there's it's in the crust
maybe the crust has more aluminum than
it does have iron but I would go with
iron seems a little darker also I think
I got that one
oh don't do that
regarding data storage what does the
acronym SSD stand for solid-state drive
not storage state drive you dummy me I'm
not dummy me I'm smart oh all right what
year it was 2004 2008 I had it in senior
high school and I graduated Oh seven
this way boom I'm right you're wrong in
our solar system which two planets
rotate clockwise
Venus and Uranus I always bet on Uranus
I always bet on year what year was
Facebook fat I thought I already did
this one mm ooh
who's real dark it's real dark God's
real dark what is the three-letter
Airport code for the Los Angeles
International Airport I know that one
you win
okay great i won good job me I'm so
happy I was a little silly it's usually
like the middle one and these are just a
little bit to the silly side of things
but that's okay
sometimes the world needs a little bit
of silly horror in their life to get
them ready for the primal terror of
darkness dwells oh yes this one I
believe this one is kind of like a five
nights at Freddy's style game but in a
different mechanic you got to use your
flashlights to keep the monsters from
killing you so if you remember the snow
based game this one is more like that
one
so after use flashlights eat interact
with objects such as the radio are to
wind your flashlights LMB to pull up
your blanket flash your flashlight at
the rocking horse when the rocking gets
faster when the cupboard opens shine
your flashlight at the door is loud
noises make them come faster keep the
radio that's not true that's enough time
go to sleep kiddo I'll check in on you
soon I promise okay
alright thanks for the crappy Skype call
connection dad whoa
my sheets were the monster pulling nose
away from me those are the mouse
sensitivities real high Oinky Oinky
don't back you give me those oh well I
guess my sheet searches yeah gone I
guess oh boy let's see on the radio okay
all right give me my sheets don't
uncover my my invisible body up okay
hello what the [ __ ] you know he
accidentally hands me his flashlight
he's like check this out sorry it's just
a little ballet dancer with the light on
it's all good I swam all right let's do
this ain't gonna I gave my future good
yeah none of it
all right let's see what you got ah all
right so I just kind of stay alive right
that's the the objective of every you
know okay I can just hold down left
mouse button both no stop the rock oh I
didn't expect there to be actually
anybody all right
oh I don't like the face in that closet
I really don't like the facing Oh Josh I
get back give me give me
can I have I'm left mousing as oh there
we go
[Music]
not no poke you know what I'm gonna just
experiment and see what it's like to die
to you cuz I don't like your face you
look like ooh oh that's horrible
oh that's horrible okay bring I'm really
losing these aren't I
no don't not lightning okay you know
what I'm just gonna let I'm gonna let
you get curious
you got an ugly face but I bet you're
not that scary up oh no no no no no no
no no no oh I hate you
oh you're like everything from my oh you
dog horrible oh oh
not dad not if I horrible mangled corpse
just don't worry you remember you tall
you gave me a flashlight decked myself
that's it let's try to survive the night
and like most children we get no sleep
because we're trying not to die what's
with the warbles why do I wear the
warbles don't warble at me Oh doll
warble no ha no you know that's what you
get used to be scared
oh that's okay I can do this at the same
time pulling on my sheets very
ambidextrous I'm capable of doing
multiple things oh whoa whoa okay all
right got that one I guess it was a
quick okay so it's all the pulling crank
is what I was what I got a combo with I
got a really really cranking yank
cuz the cranking yank that's what it is
I got a crank my flashlight around and
yank on my sheets taught outside no not
to okay this is just unpleasant why
would you do that
don't don't that's right Greg and yank
Greg and yank
oh no Greg and yank could be good to it
asleep interpreted as masturbation okay
you are the worst I do not like you you
remind me of like from the movie it did
you for any of you saw it you know the
painting lady that's who that reminds me
of like straight out of the painting
lady which is the most horrible monster
anybody has ever made in any horror
movie ever and I would stake my life on
that I don't know why keeps whining tell
me not to tell me to turn off the radio
I kind of have a deeper understanding
whose fan than you think I do which is
not great but okay crushing loneliness
painting lady's husband you know this
happens every night when you're going to
bed when you're alone in your room
there's things peering at you from the
closet there's things on your rocking
horse
there's things trying to yank the
blankets out from under you why do you
think when you wake up every morning the
blankets are never tucked in as they
used to be just because you're fighting
a battle with the demon it's just like
the game I played a while back
also just pulling the Yankee dove the
limbs the really weird leaf laylee guy
this guy this is a long night can I you
know good daylight come I want to go
home there's no indication of time I
don't know when times passing how will I
know how will I know my dog whoa whoa
whoa that was a fast rocking horse I
didn't intend for that no sorry I wasn't
paying attention and therefore I almost
died that's the punishment all the
little boys and girls around the world
should take from this if you don't pay
attention monsters we're gonna get
Johnny oh I'm family you dad not okay
it's obviously not okay why would you
say who's okay it's clearly bad all
right that is darkness dwells thank you
everybody so much for watching and thank
you everybody for being patient while I
sign 35,000 calendars during my exile
almost everybody is going to get them
very soon they're all gonna ship out
very soon but I have been told that one
or two or maybe 20 people got mysterious
calendars that weren't signed I signed
everyone that was in front of me but if
you did please send an email to hello at
mark Blair comm contact the people on
the website and then we'll get you one
in short order but it wasn't my fault
clearly obviously this face can do no
wrong and if you're in Australia and for
those people in Amsterdam that missed
our show because we were sick and had to
cancel we're coming back to you in July
all the information is available in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching and if you want play
these games for yourself you can find
the links in the description as well
thanks again everybody for watching get
ready for more cool stuff check out the
other videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]